hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark wood I did
decide to play a little bit more of this
because the game just intrigues me the
soulless stuff going on in some horrible
things happening to people good people
like me out of my face again with the
slamming but Oh before I go I remembered
why I needed to come back which was to
barricade up some more stuff in my house
blood I think the only thing I would
need to barricade would be this door
because I like the idea of being in here
rather and close so I'm gonna put the
wood that I have here in there I'm gonna
craft me up a weapon that it's not a
very good one but hey it'll be something
just in case something's coming after me
I think fine then if you gonna be like
that there we go learn goddamnit there
we go I got it nevermind okay antidote
cures and protects from poisons for a
limited time that seems awesome only
takes one mushroom love it
better than dosing myself up with
mushroom meth and just doing a bunch of
drugs drugs are bad kid gag kids and
whatever okay so I got that it's fine
I'll put that with long with uh how do I
just do a little bit of the nails I
don't want all right I'll find more
nails I'll find more nails is fine okay
until I find a pellet gun I don't need
those pellets so I don't need them in my
inventory I do need the lockpick
I need the card for the quest and I'm on
my way I'm out the door up the door with
a whole lot less so how am I going okay
so I haven't been to the north east and
I think that's where the kid said his
parents house is I don't have a lot of
stuff but I do have a plank of wood
nails nails that's good right that's
gonna make me survive so I can see a
little farther but animals are
supposedly a little more aggressive
towards me that's it that's good
everything's good everything in this
game is just fine and I love it I'm how
happy to play it more stuff more junk my
favorite I'm not trusting corpses now I
guess I do have an antidote so I guess
so would hope okay cool
this guy had a lot of stuff good thing I
trusted him holy crap what did I get ya
those seem awesome but what are they
okay whatever I'm
away I'll trade off stuff I'm not gonna
go back and drop off cuz I have a
feeling that I'm gonna be playing the
juggling game with my inventory for a
long time coming okay would more nails
mushrooms I love it I'm doing good kind
of maybe a little bit Scott hey there
hey there Sonny Jim Kolbe uh who's uh
who's causing noises that's a lot of
goopy do I really gotta go into the I
gotta go into the goop II don't know I
do not like going into the goopy areas
there's weirdos in here
yeah yeah okay guys this game is tense I
mean it's not like a traditional what is
the Oh Oh Pio tricks wait Pio tricks
that's not the guys parents's no it
isn't it isn't is it
I found Pele chick he's a weirdo he's
where I burned myself alive uh I'll find
a lot of stuff that's cool like Hello
okay
I don't trust nothing okay
board it up board it up okay might be
able to make it in one of these windows
what is that what is that lovely sound I
think I got to go around maybe or can I
jump this fence I cannot fly must go
around I guess here we go got it got it
got it okay I'm in here I'm in here Mina
oh god Davis that's already ah
why no oh God why no oh well I will
fight you to the last man
oh this fans the fill with junk oh you
wanna fight bra come on come on I got
pills for days
what gonna go in here though I'm not
scared
oh god damn but I got to do the thing
with the thing Oh would you go okay you
go you go you go crazy do a crazy friend
huh I gotta get back home oh you guys
doing to me but I gotta get back home I
have time to deal with this oh yeah that
was just a cool be over there got it so
I gotta get home I can't I can't be here
can't be here
gotta go gotta go
don't care if there's a crazy villager
over there I am gone guests or stuff
sweet okay I'm out I'm Audi
oh god that dog ran right by me okay
let's be calm about this okay
get out my way rabbit Lilly really
rabbit okay got a rabbit got remedy
don't know what I can do to trade that
out but I guess nothing bye bye rhyming
means sorry I killed you thought I could
use you for something
okay don't lose it here do not lose it
dying would be very bad you got too many
mutation thingies and I don't have time
to pick up anything else okay just got
to find a landmark there hey hi hi hi hi
what I thought oh no it's very dark oh
god I need to get back
I don't have the melty sickness yet oh
where am I where am I I don't know where
I am why did I check the map it's not
gonna tell me it doesn't like me enough
to tell me where's the road Oh give me a
landmark is that the broken tree I think
that's the broken tree yeah so it's
immediately left over here one whoa
Steven time to drink from the well ya
know we made it's dry at the moment it
looks pretty night to me hey I'm not
gonna do well uh sure well maybe I'll be
fine if I just cook up more mushroom
meth okay I'll wait until that glows I'm
gonna cook up the mushrooms that I have
I don't know if it's gonna send me on a
wild trip again no not what I wanted
give me those
okay no problem
yes one more dose all right what do we
got okay so I already took care of that
I took care of my one thing dodge Walt
wheel the meal that sounds really good I
like the ability to dodge that sounds
good to me
all right it's the time yet why is it
not time yet what time does it need to
be to beat okay it's time okay never
mind then okay sorry
oh god I go buy something I'm so
barricading this front door I don't even
care if I need you oh do it okay
that's barricaded up closing that
leaving that okay it's still a giant
hole in my house does this focus on
surviving the night I didn't even turn
power on I am so good I'm so dead I'm
dead
why does this have a code in my own
house
the same code as one I got from the
nightmare wrong code okay never mind
just got to survive one more night and
then a bajillion more nights got a plank
of wood oh that's beautiful you made
that for your mother
oh she's gonna love it shut up no one's
in here
that was different that was very
different
this night is lasting way too long I'd
rather be over seems to be getting a
little brighter maybe I saw you and we
survived another day
got another day under my belt no one can
mess with me who I recover anything when
I dismantle these I don't know but I
mean it seems like a pretty sound
strategy to just lock myself in a place
alright so I got a lot of stuff here I'm
gonna drop off um see if this is a combo
and a dote healing pill then I can store
these so that I only need them in an
emergency situation that's there I don't
know why I have so much junk on me I
think that's just for crafting but I
don't have that I want to I'll start
storing the small caliber gun ammo
because if I need that in the future I
will want that readily available to me
I'm gonna put the junk away yeah I'll
craft when I get stuff and I'll have
batteries when I need the batteries I
don't need them on me nails and wood
don't necessarily need on me but I'm
gonna take it anyway I'm gonna click on
the mushrooms nope okay we're good we're
going for it to do good things I need to
get back to
Wow ok I need to get back to pee or
tricks house wait ok ok so the only bug
gonna all my face again with the
smashing in the face this is very pretty
you don't need to ugly it up let's go to
peel tricks cuz I think that he has
crafty dudes
I'll go a bit north this time try to hit
some new area get some new scavenger
balls as a shroom who is that dead body
of chapters out a dead body that
exploded on me good good good good
yeah that's right
we go now we're into some new stuff I
got a book do I do with a book maybe pal
trick was like it wherever his name is
what is that anti-tank gun oh yeah give
it to me no give it to me I get that
seems really useful that is a dead body
there's a dead body with some stuff
happening to it I'll need an empty maybe
I need an empty bottle I don't know I
don't know I don't know what I need how
would I know if I need that god there's
too many dead bodies it's making me
anxious yeah you have nothing there's no
point looking at you right there's a
room over here
it's a shroom over there I can cook up
an antidote right on the fly lots of
stuff
lots of stuff what was that some okay
again I wonder how many times I've said
what was that while I've been playing
this I think if I start going to da East
now I should be able to find key Oh
trick hopefully I have some stuff that
he would enjoy maybe who that tree looks
like a person laughs what why okay god
damn it got stopped doing the cracks
when I get close to things okay I'm
putting the edge of the forest then went
too far north
I gotta go more east EU what yeah okay
yeah go get me oh yeah whatever whatever
whatever whatever I don't care I got
stamina for days breath damn it for days
yeah yeah yeah are you still there that
dumb mistake Oh Oh God okay is he still
behind me okay what was that god I'm
freaking out okay ha what where why Oh
God stop stop stop seriously stop game
top of the cracking okay is there all
God it's there
oh so there oh so they're slowly
marching southward oh oh I'm making
noise that's what I'm doing I'm doing
the cracking Oh shrooms hidden in the
woods get the drums that's honest way
stop cracking
don't crack a lack there it is okay
see still there it's not there oh you're
still there no no no no oh what are you
do huh you want to mess with me oh I'm
such a douche er
oh so douchey oh I'm so DC it hurts
Oh God let me have to fight this thing
hide from it
oh I'm such an idiot no no no no no no
thank you I can do this all day and I
can't do that all day okay
no thank you you all find each other on
up I'm Audi I don't care what Patrick
head I'm so what what so what run you
[ __ ]
I need to take a pill but I don't have
time to step I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm
out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
you all can screw what what oh yeah
that's right I killed the bunny there
don't care don't care I don't care okay
okay now other words yet they are super
super friendly SuperDuper friendly
hey there I've time to take uphill or
bandage myself make a bandage baby seems
like a better option all right
so far so good Kott they do not want me
over at Pio tricks I just want to hang
out with my friend my good friend Pia
Devore
AI de Braun not even pronouncing his
name correctly okay throw a way to sneak
oh really that's how you dodge that
would be useful okay so we learned
something today I can dodge backwards
only backwards only backwards maybe I
could always dodge but I can now do it
with a melee weapon I think that was
what the qualifying statement was is
there a way to sneak cuz I don't know it
I might just nail this barricade I don't
care I'm coming in oh come on what is it
too complicated
did he have a specific way of ham oh oh
okay I thought I saw a shadow moving
which would have been also bad shadows
me okay
it better not start turning tonight
already because I am NOT happy about the
fact that these guys are the biggest
[ __ ] those grag yes need that okay
oh god damn it I gotta take care of the
thing in his garage
I had fire to do it before but I don't
have fire now do it can I make him oh no
I put my alcohol back home oh please
tell me has one bottle of booze
somewhere in this house please please
don't let all of this Bend for waste Oh
one bottle of booze please okay that's
not what well that's cool I guess is
that Nazi knows I'm not see how no no ah
this is my life this is the life I live
it's my living life okay well I'm
screwed
there was some one more thing over here
sloppily well together pal junk okay
okay an exhaust didn't I have another
part too
didn't I didn't I pick something up know
those the anti-tank gun that's right I
didn't actually get anything from there
stop being weird one bottle of booze I
need to burn you alive
gasoline perfect always thank you and
there's alcohol to Oh everything oh
maybe it would have given me what I need
to burn it up okay so I'm gonna do this
the old-fashioned way
good old gasoline blood love okay
probably enough let me just throw it
from very far away I know what happened
last time
push alright cool cool that's awesome
but playing with fire is bad don't do it
kids it'd be bad come on come on come on
come on come on
little really pretty fire but burn
already I'll go around screw you screw
you raging conflagration there's more in
here yep push and you burnt up your
saucy bastard can you stop with the
burning close the door on your face
maybe that would burn you know ya ain't
choice no okay there's one more thing in
here I think it's a doggy I don't know
if I need to kill the dog again
darn what's a fire what cheating dougie
yes there'd window in here I have to
though this I'm sorry very sorry please
II feel so bad oh I think I had to do
that go what if I didn't have to do it
oh yes Peleg on okay I didn't get from
him I got from in here that's right
okay book uh blueprint the rocket ship
the sky plan to go the rocket ship to
the moon this okay do I need that
connect flashlight sounds important uh I
hear some boobies oh no what's that out
there we go out one of these windows
okay no this is messing with my head
unless this isn't one of those games
were sounds mess with my head and every
sound is actually a thing that's um -
okay all right then oh hello hi again
how you doing oh you look lovely when I
first saw this guy I thought he was a
woman to be honest didn't know for
certain okay yesterday I saw a metal
thing he was laying there on the grass I
don't like grass so slippery there would
be these metal thingies do you have any
metal thingies I might hear first look
at this have you seen my vehicle almost
ready that your rocketship good good
good II okay I've got one - such a
beautiful photograph put it the doctor
weird I don't see Kagera in I've never
seen the photo without Gagarin in it he
was great man who flew to the stars I'll
reach the stars one there's some weird
thing where I played this for like an
hour I know remember what I remember and
what I don't remember oh it was all blur
of nightmares okay recipe for inventory
upgrade I want that so badly I want that
so badly cable take this empty bottle
uhm crap I need that junk oh I don't
have enough reputation with you I can
sell my rags but I'd rather not healing
pills don't so poison I can make poison
pills I guess I can forego that I really
want that inventory upgrade - don't need
the hotbar upgrade I want an inventory
upgrade please I do okay
is that all I need from you I'd like to
get that but I don't have enough
reputation I think I don't have anything
I could trade out oh my flashlight I
guess but that doesn't seem like a good
trade oh I haven't needed a flashlight
so far I can make a torch I can make it
torch I always get something later so I
didn't need to trade this junk okay give
me that I'll take all of it I'll take
all of it yes I exactly like all of this
okay gossip haven't slept for days such
a beautiful thing space does space does
is everywhere okay you have fun with
being insane I'll I'll go on my way I
need to get back home so I can start
doing things I don't know I don't know
what there's no clock
maybe he's one day I can craft up a
clock but for now I'm just on left to my
own devices oh this guy had booze I
forgot that guy had
I don't remember things when I'm running
for my life screaming like a ninny
yeah I think there might have been
something else in pea Oryx place PA
doors
what is it name I don't even know how to
pronounce it I think there might have
been more stuff in his house that I
could get but I'm not gonna worry about
that just now when we get back to my
house I'm gonna craft a bunch of bunch
of stuff I got some pellets waiting for
me please tell me I didn't die put my
pills away I did don't blow me up okay I
already searched you I'm not gonna do it
again you know it's weird I got the
counterpoint I got the
point/counterpoint of animals being more
aggressive to me and less aggressive to
me I don't know what means right cuz I
think that I'm okay but at the same time
I really don't know whatever just get
back in craft up a gun a grind a pellet
gun
it leads good enough jump please thank
you
there's more shrooms to put in the pot
more mushroom meth for my own lovely arm
not enough to do anything though I want
to learn these upgrades learn learn
learn okay so I need one what is that
what is that excuse me that was the
sound of footsteps in my house I don't
like that oh boy were you oh all right
let's see what I need to make the gun
need
oh no wire no wire oh I think the wolf
had wire I'm gonna get some stuff to
trade to him ah
come on that's such a ball you know
that's bull God is getting dark already
I haven't even found the Wolf's camp
wolf man whatever whatever whatever he
is I don't even care what he is
he's a douche douche man that's who he
is haha
why is everything gotta be a pain in the
ass must return to my hideout I've got
time I know I oh god wolf right there
God they are not aggressive towards me
didn't even growl at me oh well you
didn't fly away okay you're just kind of
sputtered there for a second I'm not
gonna be able to find this wolf please
let it be easy to find the wolf I want a
pellet gun behind these goobies isn't he
see in this goobie area who's behind it
Scooby oh whoa dog okay looky looky
okay okay okay okay they're being
awfully kind to me okay find the old man
cap yes thank you so much oh that is
cool I like that kinda can't stack that
enough okay I'm gonna trade some stuff
with him then I'm gonna come back get
this stuff trade then
I gotta move gotta move fast on this on
okay found you okay you want to take
this booze why did I got stack those
take the booze take those booze take one
of these take days
ah I need what do I need wire you don't
have wire thought you had wire shovel I
guess I get to get the holes if I had a
shovel God why don't you have wire Oh
so dad is all dead I'll take more
pellets I'm gonna soon out the pellet
gun I guess - dad alright I go and let
me go grab the stuff from the bag trade
off the UH not so empty I don't have
room we mean I don't have room my MIDI
Christmas right whatever
ha hey whoa hey whoa dog that dog got
close to me maybe that means I can tame
a dog sound what that means it's not
what I could mean I doesn't want the
gasoline take my planking nails oh oh oh
I do not have time for this
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
oh wait it's night already I got to move
I got a wolf man we got no time for this
yes oh that's awesome I can turn wood
and nails in the currency for this guy
Oh perfect perfect perfect perfect
very very perfect okay we're good we're
good are we good we're straight you
don't have wire hate you but that's okay
maybe the other guy had wire I don't
know God that the dog wants to say hi to
me is he like my friend now he is
following me looks nice find me I'd give
it to you okay
don't have time to that gotta get home
Oh
hum was with it just why oh god it is
dark can't I see anything maybe cuz
there was something in my way
okay good straight Northwest Northwest
Northwest is best
oh god it's dark
oh I really goofed up didn't I oh god I
really goofed up in the clearing okay
okay there's the road there's a dead
body the uh yeah just to the left of
here right yes okay we're okay we're
okay we're so okay oh okay okay we're
okay not even time to drink blood yet
blood Oh from the well well of blood I
can go in here I can have a fun time
with my shrooms draftees oh good I'll be
so good oh wait I didn't pick up any
shrooms but I can't make again but I can
put gas in the thing yes that's a good
idea
I don't know if that's a good idea I
really think that they could see more if
I do this okay let me just blub blub
blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
blub blub okay there we go tank empty
I'm not even gonna switch it on you have
anything else nope you're just uh empty
corpse was it time yet nah oh yeah that
it might be time yet I got a drink oh I
see it I got a drink okay guys drink all
this bad why am i outside right now
stop screaming huh I'm not screaming I'm
an old man huh I don't have enough for
that good huh oh god okay I'm in here
it's okay it's all good got nails how's
that barricade good okay no okay so
we're good to go
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna end
the episode here I'm sure I'll be fine
through this night but either way thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
lockpick okay oh my god